Mike this is a game called who's your
daddy it's creepy yeah it's a real big
hit on the Internet where you both take
turns playing as the baby and the daddy
the baby what you oh my god yeah yeah so
like a fetus and a baby you do um yeah
you look real great with that hat on
whoa so yeah you the premise of the game
is uh you are trying to kill yourself
and I'm trying to prevent that so yeah
you're trying to go for this pork and
you can then wait whoo baby shard within
seconds of them match starting yeah you
know so that's how it goes so let's uh
give it a couple rounds so yeah I'm
actually still trying to figure out this
game myself oh there's like different
things youcam it you can do oh here's
some batteries like I haven't figured
out that lock yet mmm baby like battery
so now your poison mm-hm and I need to
find pills who I'm tripping the Garhwal
you put that up here something good I'm
thirsty for some pain worthy pills I
can't find it they're probably all
upstairs yes [ __ ] I think that's what's
weird is like the pills are frustrating
for the dad because they seem to like
respawn different places yeah it's kind
of procedural in that respect did you
damn it i just found pills they were
right there uh let's go again what's
your plan today my son nothing just
thirsty oh so craving poison whoa see
like this is a new item here
maybe restraint get away from me with
that I haven't seen this before was that
come here my child what are you doing I
don't know I'm gonna try to fear oh my
god what am I supposed to do hmm so i
really take care of my kids what is this
oh dude oh yeah oh that you're saying
interesting oh I'm invisible I well this
is uh this way you call it game breaking
ball me this is weak now you're just a
hair a knife that's invisible Oh Mike
late yeah I don't know are you web
where'd you go nowhere don't worry about
yeah all right well he's my visible mod
no not really had no idea what I did at
all right well that was a little cheap
so far I don't think I've seen the dad
reign supreme nope stuff nope oh yeah oh
yeah I'm getting real hot in here oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah did you did you cuz
that's a win what nothing could you turn
the knobs yeah I turns on it turned a
bunch of a long were you bad oh no
batteries batteries are good and my son
where were the pills that's like well
the first things you guys do with the
dad go go go come here come here baby
you can't catch me it's so poisoning is
giving me powers get your knees out of
your chest yeah I get you your pills
yeah I no way I just what are these no
oh oh no knife or baby go oh you took it
didn't you I damn sure
come into this corner and die you have
no idea where I am you don't even know
I'm not letting you look my screen
either Oh Billy no get away from me stay
away okay yeah I don't slow down the
poisoning oh man doesn't good what time
is it before yet baby daddy oh daddy
wins look at that I'm a good dad well
that is who's your daddy Mike it's a
real hit it isn't really access it's
five dollars on steam why do I couldn't
use let me have that one I don't know
I'm actually like pretty happy that I
was able to pull that over your dad of
the year whatever cool well thank you
very much Mike thanks for having me